[Music]
good evening my name is Alexander oz on
the director here at long now and as you
know at the beginning of most of these
talks we do what's called the long short
a short film that in some way
exemplifies long-term thinking tonight's
comes from some some members who are
here in the room where are you wave your
hands to out there you are in the back
of the room thank you
and actually it's a it's a good point to
remind you all that actually finding
these long shorts is quite difficult so
if you have good candidates please send
them in to us or make some of your own
like like these guys did which are which
is a really great one and I think
tonight's long short is interesting I
mean we're definitely going to go vastly
further into the past
then tonight's long short is but part of
civilizations fragility comes both from
its interconnectedness and that's also
one of the things that really make
civilization robust so I think tonight's
longshore it shows a little bit of each
of that enjoy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
good evening I'm Stuart brand from the
long now foundation as you know the long
now we define as the next 10,000 years
which we're building a clock for in the
last 10,000 years which we're still
figuring out what happened part of the
idea of all that is to sort of calibrate
how we think about time and history in
eternity which doesn't actually play
into this at all forever is not part of
this story but time has size and we're
pretty good at the minutes and hours and
the kind of stuff we saw in the film
here we're still figuring out decades
centuries millennia so half the way back
5,000 years ago was the beginning of the
Bronze Age
we started to get bronze tools and
weapons and the kind of society that can
use those things and that went on for
2,000 years and then it ended much more
suddenly than it began and we have a
speaker who knows more about that than
anybody Eric Cline
thank you so much for inviting me here
thank you all for coming I'm presuming
you're out there it's hard for me to see
but what I would like to do tonight in
the next hour or so is to take you back
take you back between 4000 and 3000
years ago to the time that is my
favorite period in ancient history Late
Bronze Age 1700 to 1200 BC if I could be
reincarnated backwards that's the period
I would like to live in I don't think
I'd survive for about more than 48 hours
but it would be a marvelous 48 hours now
this is the period when we have what I
would call the g8 of the ancient world
and I'm cheating a little bit because in
order to do that I have to combine the
Minoans and the Mycenaeans of Greece
into one entity but we have them on the
edge of the screen there we also have
the Hittites in purple up here in Turkey
Mitani is in red Assyrians and
Babylonians and they're in kind of a
mustard yellow and then Egyptians are
the orange going up the Nile and into
Canaan we also have Cypriots and other
people as well now all of these people
are interacting in the time period that
we're going to talk about and I dare say
that you actually know more about that
time period already then you might
suspect so for example this is the time
when hatshepsut lives the famous female
pharaoh how many people have heard of
her okay top Moses the third one of the
greatest military conquerors lives at
that time my boy Amenhotep the third
he's the guy I most wish I could meet in
antiquity Akhenaten the famous Heretic
Pharaoh I dare say you've heard of him
King Tut that's the man that everybody
knows Ramses the second Ramses the third
this is the time period that we're
talking about and during these centuries
everything flourished it was in fact a
time that was almost globalized if we
can use that word and put it project it
back
into the past but with that comes other
things too not just trade not just
diplomacy but things like Wars so for
example we've got the Battle of Kadesh
between the Hittites and the Egyptians
we've got a little thing called the
Trojan War right you may have seen a
movie that Brad Pitt was in we also have
things like the Exodus which if it took
place will have taken place at about
this time period now what we've got is a
globalized society in which everyone is
interconnected if you know the six
degrees of Kevin Bacon we've kind of got
that here as well this is a social
network diagram that my wife Diane Kline
made and you can see that pretty much
everybody is interconnected in some way
if the Mycenaeans and the Hittites
aren't directly connected they know
somebody who can connect them and in
fact we've got writing from that time
period
such as this this is a typical cuneiform
tablet looks like a bird a stepped in
ink and walked across the page there's
an archive that dates to about 1350 BC
in which we found about 400 of these
tablets and their letters to and fro to
and from the kings of that time period
the king of the Hittites king of
Egyptians king of Babylon king of
Assyria and also to the vassal Kings the
ones that owed them allegiance and if
you map them you can see that we really
are talking about a small world effect
which is where again if you don't know
the person at least you know somebody in
between and usually there's no more than
about three leaps that separate any
particular person so if you map these
out as my wife did here you can see with
a couple of huge nodes with the king of
Egypt and the king of the Hittites and
so on that pretty much everybody is in
contact with everyone else so I know
that saying that that time period is
globalized as a loaded term and yet I
think we can use it it was globalized
for its time period and that is from
Italy on the west to Afghanistan on the
east everybody is in contact they're
trading they are
swapping raw materials gold silver
copper tin they're also trading finished
goods now this is the Bronze Age which
starts in about 3000 BC it's all gonna
come collapsing down at about 1200 BC so
what I actually want to do tonight is to
build this up show you what they were
doing
what was there and then collapse it all
down by the time we're done we don't
know why they collapsed and that's part
of the mystery and that's part of what I
will talk about but before I collapse it
let me build it up so this is the Bronze
Age to make bronze you need ten and you
need copper by the way if you don't have
ten you can also use arsenic I don't
recommend that but you won't live very
long but you can make our cynical copper
but ten is much better 90% copper 10%
tin and you'll get your bronze now the
copper is not a problem the copper is
gonna come from Cyprus in fact that's
where the name comes from keep rose it
means copper the tin is a little bit
more difficult there's some ten of
course up in Cornwall there's some in
southeastern Turkey but not enough most
of the tin seems to be coming from an
area off this map you can see the arrow
going off it is in fact an area in what
is modern-day Afghanistan the Badakhshan
region and in fact not only Tim comes
from there anybody here have lapis
lazuli jewelry lapis also comes from
that region so what we've got is the
need to get tin all the way into the
region of Mesopotamia Egypt the Aegean
and this is going to involve trade
routes that can be hundreds or even
thousands of miles long and in fact we
know that they are doing this there is a
letter at Mari which is in Syria on the
river they're not sure if Mari actually
exists anymore
Isis has occupied it and is looting it
so we don't know if it's still there but
there was a cache of letters found and
among them was a an itinerary in which
it described
ten coming from Afghanistan to Mari in
what is now Syria then going on to
Garrett on the northern coast of Syria
and then going from there over to Crete
and in fact it says that at Boogaard
which is right up there that there is in
fact a man from Crete a Minoan who can
speak the local language he is the
translator so we know that they are
sending tin all over there and in fact a
good friend of mine Carol Bell she's a
British archeologist she has said that
their need for tin is basically the
equivalent of our need for oil and that
the search for tin would have occupied
the king of Egypt and the King up in the
hittite region in Turkey just as the
search for oil today occupies like a US
president so if you can think of that
kind of a parallel that's what we've got
here but as I say they're not only
trading for raw materials they're also
trading finished goods and in these Mari
letters which actually date a little bit
earlier than our period that date to
about 1800 BC so just under 4,000 years
ago we have one text that describes a a
weapon that's being brought from Crete
says one calf torreón weapon calf door
is their name for Crete and the Minoans
the top and the base are covered with
gold its top is encrusted with lapis
lazuli so it would have looked something
like this though this isn't it because
this is from the death pits of war
dating to about 2500 BC but nevertheless
it's quite nice and I wouldn't actually
mind having one of these not sure I'd be
able to carry it but I wouldn't mind so
this is one good example of what they're
sending back and forth but my absolute
favorite and it shows that nothing has
really changed is a text that talks
about what must be sandals that says one
pair of leather shoes and the calf
Dorian style now if anybody has been
decreed you know that cafetorium starrer
Minoan style are either sandals or boots
you can still get a nice pair of boots
at Chania I suspect they're sandals but
I'm not sure
but the text then says which to the
palace of Hammurabi the king of Babylon
and yes that is the Hammurabi and eye
for an eye a tooth for a tooth
but the limb carried them but which were
returned for the life of me I can't
figure out why they were returned were
they too small were they to last
millennium and in fact I asked my
students wants to read through the whole
lock code there's about 272 laws and I
said find me the law with the penalty
for returning shoes they came back and
they said there isn't one we can't find
it I said exactly he got away with it
but I still don't know wouldn't you have
kept them in at least re-gifted them so
things have not changed all that much so
basically my point here is they are
trading finished goods and raw materials
and they are in fact going back and
forth between the different countries we
know for example that hatshepsut sends
an embassy down to punt we don't quite
know where point was or at least we
didn't know until recently but on her
mortuary temple she has descriptions and
pictures of the ships that went she even
has pictures of the goods that are
brought back and she even tells us in
the lowest picture there that the Queen
is named Ettie so we know all about this
the problem was as I said we didn't
quite know where punt was until recently
and then someone did an analysis of some
baboon mummies in the British Museum and
determined that they were most closely
related to baboons in Eritrea or
Ethiopia and that was one of the
possibilities for punt so that's
probably where it was now she wasn't the
first person to send embassies there and
she's not the last but that's what she
is known for other embassies though
other trade missions may have gone over
to the Aegean to Greece
here is the tomb of wreck Moray and in
here wreck Moray is what the Vizier
liked the right-hand man to the Pharaoh
we see people from Greece
these are Minoans or Mycenaeans and
they're bringing typical Aegean Goods
to Egypt same thing here in this tomb
again we have you can see somebody is
carrying a Bulls head that's straight
out of Konoe sauce so we know that Egypt
and Greece are trading already back at
well about 1400 1450 BC would be when
this has taken place and it continues
this is Amenhotep the thirds mortuary
temple i wager that some of you have
seen these the colossi of memnon they're
about 60 feet tall and in fact there
were Greek and Roman tourists that went
to see these they scratch their names
Kilroy Was here but in Greek what you
don't see is the missing mortuary temple
that these were at the entrance to
because it was stolen by the later
Pharaohs why go out and quarry more
stone when you can just take this from a
dead Pharaoh and make your own temple so
most of them are now gone now much more
interesting to my mind than the big
60-foot tall ones are the smaller ones
that were probably only about ten feet
tall you can't see these statues anymore
they're gone you just see the feet here
but in the 1960s German archeologists
were excavating and they found five of
the statue base lists they hypothesized
there were ten in fact the new
excavations that are there now have
revealed more than 40 of the statue base
lists on each of these bases are the
names of foreign powers foreign
countries one mentions places that we
know belonged to the Hittites another
one mentions the Babylonians and the
Assyrians but this particular one is the
one that caught my interest the Aegean
list it has names that had never
appeared in Egypt before and would never
appear again for the most part because
what you see on one side is two names
over here which are the head names for
the lists
kofte you and Tenaya CAFTA you is the
egyptian name for crete just like they
called a calf door up in Mesopotamia
in Egypt they call it kofte you Taniya
is probably mainland Greece so we've got
crete and mainland greece and then on
the other side and going around the edge
we've got a series of 14 names that
mention again places that had never been
written down in egypt before amny sauce
Vestas cadonia Nicene i caddos acro not
Theon Elios Cano sauce and amny sauce
again which is kind of interesting now
the very first time it was deciphered
when it was translated in english ken
kitchen a rather a preeminent british
scholar published and he said i'm rather
hesitant to suggest this but this looks
uncomfortably like my sinaia no sauce
well uncomfortable enough it was my
scene I and Cano sauce and this list is
basically one of a kind but if you go
over to Greece and you look at the
sights that are mentioned on that statue
base you actually find objects with
Amenhotep the Third's name on it or his
wife Queen T they seem to have married
for love but here we've got a faience
plaque with egyptian hieroglyphs and
we've got on the right side you can see
natural nephron imatra the good god and
then the name of Amenhotep the third and
add a number of the sites that are on
the statue base we've got objects with
his name on it so for instance at canosa
on crete here is a scarab of Amenhotep
the third so i think that this is not
just boasting or bragging I actually
think it might record an itinerary of
the way to get from Egypt up to Greece
and back again and I would suspect that
maybe that's why I'm new sauce is on
here twice it's a round trip so you're
going from Egypt you get up to Crete and
you stop it's the first place get off
everybody use the bathroom it's time for
a coffee alright and then you go and
you've known the Minoans for quite a
while the Egyptians have known them
already for a couple of hundred years
but the Mycenaeans our new upstarts at
this time at about 13
50 BC so let's go up to mainland Greece
and see what's going on up there then we
cut bent down to Crete and here we are
at mu sauce again everybody used the
bathroom it's going to be a long ride
till we get back to Egypt right sound
familiar so I think that we might
actually have an itinerary here I can't
prove it but I think it's a definite
possibility one of the reasons why I say
this is because we have the remains of
actual ships that we're going around and
around the Mediterranean at that time
this is the rather well known hula
beroun shipwreck which went down off the
coast of Turkey in about 1300 BC it's
been excavated by George bass and Jamal
Pollock of Texas A&M Institute of
nautical archaeology and they found what
you're looking at here you can see the
stones going right down through the
middle with the holes in them those are
anchors there are 14 stone anchors on
here but the majority of the cargo 300
copper ingots which you see here and the
copper is 99% pure and it comes from
Cyprus so this particular ship is
carrying actually it's more than 300
ingots you can carry them on your
shoulder they each weigh about 60 pounds
it's got 10 tonnes of copper it also has
a ton of tin on this same boat
so if you mix the copper in the tin
you're looking at an awful lot of bronze
in fact George bass at one point
estimated that there is enough raw
material on board this one ship that you
could have outfitted an army of 300
soldiers with swords shields helmets
Greaves
everything that you would need to get a
modern Bronze Age army back then so when
this ship went down somebody lost a
fortune and I actually hope they were
insured now seriously there was
insurance back then we know it from the
text so it's not out of the question
that this was insured so we've got lots
and lots of copper lots and lots of 10
in fact we have other things as well the
top left-hand column our picture there
you actually have tin you can see the
round bun ingot there you've also
got in the top right-hand picture also
round ingots but this is raw glass
colored with cobalt and in fact when the
corning museum of glass analyzed these
it matched perfectly with glass from
Mycenaean Greece and New Kingdom Egypt
so they're all getting their glass from
the same place we've also got in the
lower line there all the way down bottom
on the Left terebinth resin which comes
from the pistachio tree you use it in
making perfume in the middle ivory of
course but not just from elephants also
from hippopotamus and it actually turns
out that about 90 percent of the ivory
in the Late Bronze Age is from hippo not
from elephants which people found
surprising and then new unused pottery
from Cyprus and Canaan Israel Lebanon
Syria so this is for me a microcosm of
the international trade that was going
on at the time that this ship sunk in
about 1300 BC and in fact if you plot
this on a map which National Geographic
did by the way if you're interested its
December 1987 it's my favourite issue
ever they on this map put the objects
from the ship on the map as to where
they came from they thought the ship was
going round and round and round hence
the blue arrows I'm actually not so sure
that they were doing that I think it
might be a gift from one King to another
in which case it's going straight across
but it's not out of the question it was
also on a shopping expedition because
everything they needed would have been
used by a Mycenaean Palace right so we
need raw glass we need more pistachio
resin we need some tin we need some
copper and you know get some milk while
you're out but the ship never came back
so for me this is as I say a microcosm
but we've also got the writing a text
from ooh Garrett on the north coast of
Syria dates to about 40 years after this
ship went down it's called the sinner a
new text because it mentions a merchant
a private merchant named sinner on ooo
it says from the present day on the
stammer oh the son
Nicke nepo king of wu Garrett exempts in
iran who son of segi knew by the way I
wanted to name our kids this my wife
refused for some reason at any rate
let's see his grain his beer his olive
oil to the palace he shall not deliver
his ship is exempt when it arrives from
Crete so we have a private merchant in
about 1260 BC who is importing olive oil
beer and grain and he's exempt from
taxes I actually think this might be the
first corporate tax exemption in history
but can't be sure about that so when you
combine the physical evidence from the
shipwreck and the written evidence from
the center under text I think it's
pretty clear that we've got
international trade going on so
basically what we've got we've got a
globalized society and I do use that
term wearily but interconnection Merilee
going along 17th century 16 15 14 13
everybody's having fun being diplomatic
and trading and there's reciprocity
going on and then into this a little
chaos was dropped and one by one each of
the civilizations winked out actually
they did it pretty fast the only one
that was left standing was Egypt and
even they were so weakened that they
were never the same again the New
Kingdom is the high point so just after
1200 BC we get what we called the
collapse or the calamity and pretty much
everything gets destroyed everything
that had been good everything that had
been ticking along merrily suddenly goes
out as if somebody had just snapped
their fingers now the question is what
caused it and that's been one of
history's great mysteries one thing we
can say is that the magnitude of the
collapse when it did take place was
enormous I don't think anything comes
close to it until the Roman Empire
collapsed and that was 1,500 years later
but as I say the question of what caused
it is a bit of a problem and that's
where my book comes in Rob tempio of
Princeton University Press asked me if I
would write a book about the collapse
and I said
sure but I also want to write about what
collapsed so the beginning and the end
or about the collapse in the middle is
what I've just described to you what
collapsed telling the stories about that
now I also realize that I'm not the
first person that's discussed the
collapse of civilizations there was a
guy named Edward Gibbon who wrote a
little book about the decline and fall
of the Roman Empire Joseph Tainter in
1988 put out a book the collapse of
societies of complex societies which has
been an absolute marvelous book for all
of us and then of course I imagine a
number of you have read Jared Diamond's
book on collapse the difference though
is that when the Late Bronze Age
collapsed it was a multitude of
interconnected and intertwined
civilizations that all went down at once
these books mostly are talking about the
decline of a single civilization at a
time Roman Empire Maya Mongols Indus
Valley we are rather unique here in the
Late Bronze Age in that that is one of
the few times when you actually had
interconnected civilizations much as we
have today so I actually think the
parallels between us today and then back
then are much stronger than you might
suppose even though they were 3,200
years ago so anything that we can learn
about their collapse I think is not just
idly studying ancient history but may
contain some lessons for us today but
the big problem is trying to figure out
why they collapsed and it used to be the
easy solution everybody said oh those
the sea peoples why not sure sea peoples
well we actually know these from the
Egyptians we know that they came through
twice 12:07 BC and 1177 BC and you can
see right there that's where the title
of the book comes from but actually it
would be better to say the fifth year of
Merneptah or the eighth year of Ramses
the third be because the Egyptologists
keep changing the chronology all right
everything is you know it's on a sliding
scale so in fact when the book came out
a senior colleague of mine up in New
York sent me an email in which he said
nice job congratulations
title should have been 1186 I sent him
back a two-word email and no it's not
what you think my email to him simply
said it was and in fact in the contract
I signed the title was originally 1186
BC but in the years that I was doing the
research and the writing the
Egyptologist changed the chronology
again and so it became 1177 in the
interval since the book has come out
they've changed the chronology again and
so the next editions going to have to be
called 1188 anyway so for us let's just
say the eighth year of Rameses the third
well what happens here he actually tells
us in both pictures and texts and he
shows us the naval battle and talks
about the land battle and he says and
I'll quote here the foreign countries
made a conspiracy in their islands all
that once the lands were removed and
scattered in the fray no land could
stand before their arms from hot a code
a cart commish arts awha and the last
year on now we know where those places
are kotti those are the Hittites up in
Turkey code a and carcass that swear
turkey joins Syria arts awaaz on the
western coast of Turkey Elijah that's
the ancient name for Cyprus so we can
see that these people are basically
coming across Greece to Turkey to Cyprus
and then into Canaan because he
continues a camp was set up in one place
in a more omuro is by Ugarit on the
north coast of Syria they desolated its
people its land was like that which
comes never come into being they were
coming forward toward Egypt while the
flame was prepared before them and then
he gives us the names of the peoples
because there's not just one Sea Peoples
in fact he doesn't call them the sea
peoples that's our name for him right he
gives us the actual groups the polis at
the - jackar the shekel s the denyen and
the West and then he says that he
defeated them and we know this from his
year twelve papyrus Harris says I
overthrew those who invaded from their
lands I slew the denyen who are in their
aisles the two jacker and the policy
were made ashes the shardana and the
west of the sea they were made as those
that exist not so you can see how we've
got the name the peoples of the sea but
he actually gives us the names in fact
when you combine this with the earlier
invasion thirty years previously there's
nine of these groups that all come in so
the big question that we've got is who
are these people where did they come
from
and where did they go to now we know
what they look like because Ramsay's
shows us them these are pictures of
captive sea peoples in fact if you want
to dress up at Halloween that's quite
easy to do it but trying to find where
they came from is more and more
difficult so people have been playing
for example linguistic games so shardana
named me a place in the mediterranean
that has similar consonants where they
could have come from and give you him
look in the western Mediterranean
Sardinia people have suggested that's
where they came from
same thing with shekel Esch nearby
Sicily possibly - jackar maybe somewhere
in Italy or Turkey the denyen some
people have suggested that these are the
denounced Homer's Mycenaean Greeks
Wesch we're not quite sure about maybe
from will OSA it's only the police' that
we think we know the Philistines and in
fact jean-francois Champollion the guy
who deciphered Egyptian hieroglyphics he
had already suggested that the police
were the Philistines way back in 1823 or
so now one of the problems we've got
though is did they come from there or
did they go there afterward right are
they from Sardinia or is that where they
fled after they were defeated and we
don't know the answers all I can tell
you right now is that no site has been
excavated where we can definitively say
that's where the sea peoples come from
they are a mystery we do know where some
of them ended up the Philistines the
police' they wind up in what is now
Israel Lebanon Syria
and in fact you can see from this
Philistine stirrup jar it's what we
would call degenerate mycenaean it looks
like somebody from Greece is still
making their pots their stirrup jars but
they're now using local clay from roads
or Cyprus or even Canaan ancient Israel
so it really looks like at least part of
the Mycenaeans had joined the Sea
Peoples maybe after they lost and in
fact I suspect that that's why we've got
the disparate groups as these people
swept over the lands some of the people
they were vanquishing joined in so what
we see in Egypt is the end of the
process this motley crew but they're not
Vikings
they're not Raiders we shouldn't be
thinking like that because in the
pictures that Rameses shows us he shows
us and you can see on the left and also
the drawing on the right there they're
coming with their possessions they're
coming with ox carts they're coming with
wives and children's this is a migration
this is a movement think 1930s Dust Bowl
and everybody moving from Oklahoma to
California that's what this is it's a
migration it's not just Viking raids so
then the question is well what caused
that and for the longest time there was
a very simple logical linear explanation
that there was a drought and that
drought led to famine and that led to
the movement of the sea peoples that led
to havoc and the cutting of the trade
routes and that led to collapse and it's
a nice easily told bedtime story or
perhaps not bedtime but the problem is
it's too logical it's too messy nothing
is that logical I think it's too simple
so what really happened well that was
what I wanted to investigate if
everything was gone what caused it why
did everything collapse so suddenly so
the sea peoples were usually blamed for
it but I actually think they were as
much the victims as they were the
oppressors I think they've been given a
bad name they got bad press yes they
were there yes they did some damage but
I think they
had a little bit of problem themselves
so what else could have caused it
well drought has been suggested famines
been suggested invaders have been
suggested earthquakes have been
suggested so if we have to pick and
choose one of them I respectfully
decline
I would choose them all I think there's
a perfect storm I think they all
happened let me present the evidence to
you rather quickly and then see what you
think
drought is not a recent suggestion in
fact Reese carpenter who was a professor
at Bryn Mawr suggested this in the 1960s
he said that the Mycenaeans had declined
and gone downhill very quickly because
of drought but he didn't have proof for
it he didn't have any hard data and so
people gradually forgot that he had
suggested this but we now have that data
we've got it in the last five years
Connie uski a French professor has been
going with this team to a number of
different places and they went here to
the north coast of Syria place called
Gabala and they took course from
dried-up lagoons and lakes and then they
looked at the pollen that was in there
and they decided they could see that the
plants had changed and there was what
they call a 300 year dry event in other
words a drought and the pollen shows
that there were drier climatic changes
back then from about the 12th century or
the 13th century right right about our
time period just after 1200 all the way
down to the ninth century so 300 years
so north Syria looks like it had a
drought they wanted went over to Cyprus
did the same thing at hala Sultan teki
same thing there is a drought there as
well from 1200 to about 850 BC judging
from the pollen and then Brandon Drake
pulled together a bunch of different
data and a study that was published in
the journal of archaeological science
including things like the
/ of the sea which dropped and when you
do that you get less rain on the in this
case the mycenaean or Greek mainland and
he said that took place about 1250 down
to 11 97 BC now
Brandon's article was so good I did
something that I rarely do I wanted to
contact him and give him my
congratulations so superb article so I
googled him all I knew was that it was
Brandon Drake from University of New
Mexico and Google came up on the very
first thing it said was you are friends
in facebook really so I sent an email to
him and he's like hey Eric how's it
going I haven't seen you since Megiddo
in 2006 alright we dug together so you
may know people you don't even know you
know the power of the Internet the most
recent of these scientific tests has
taken place with Daphnia on route who
you can see in the picture down there in
Israel Finkelstein and Thomas litt -
German scientist they also did the
coring and the pollen analysis this time
from the Sea of Galilee and the Dead Sea
and they showed that in Israel - there
was a drought it didn't last quite as
long it was from about 1250 down to 1100
BC but so we've now got that missing
data that Rhys Carpenter was looking for
that there was a dry event a drought
that lasted from well at least 13 or
1200 BC down - take your pick 11:50 900
somewhere in there and it's in Israel
it's in Syria it's in Cyprus it's in
Greece so at least the science is
telling us that there is a drought and
of course the media went wild over this
right New York Times pollen study points
to drought as culprit in Bronze Age
mystery LA Times got into the act
climate change may have caused demise of
Late Bronze Age civilizations
archaeology magazine and National
Geographic didn't want to be left out
there's Nat Geo here's archaeology new
york post got into it they tossed in
globalization for good measure
globalization and climate change
destroyed ancient civilization and then
you may remember that NASA funded study
that turned out to be not so funded by
NASA that said that we were going to
collapse in just a couple of decades and
at that point I was a little fed up so I
put a an op-ed in The Huffington Post
the collapse of civilizations it's
complicated which it is now with drought
you frequently get famine but famine can
be difficult to discern in the
archaeological record unless you find
bodies and things like that but that's
where written texts come in and in fact
we've got archives at jugar which tell
us that in fact that's what's going on
here is a letter from the house of or
Taino he's another one of those private
merchants like sonora no only a hundred
or more years later he has a outlying
office in the city of Amar in inland
Syria and he gets word back there is
famine in our house we will all die of
hunger if you do not quickly arrive here
we ourselves will die of hunger you will
not see a living soul from your land so
I think you can agree with me that
there's probably famine going on there
we've cut the written records and we've
even got this from the kingdom of God
another letter here with me plenty has
become famine I think this is
incontrovertible evidence even the
hittite king do you not know that there
was a famine in the midst of my lands it
is a matter of life and death and in
fact we know from other records that the
Egyptians who until recently had been
mortal enemies of the Hittites were
sending grain ships up to help a leave
the famine in the hittite lands so we've
got that going on which we see the same
sort of things today now adding insult
to injury though do we have invaders
well yes we do see peoples remember them
the Egyptian records but it can be tough
sometimes to figure out who's causing
your destruction so it could just as
easily be internal rebellion and in fact
we've got yet another letter from the
in this case being sent to the king of
Cyprus and he says my father now the
ships of the enemy have come they've
been setting fire to my cities and have
done harm to the land doesn't my father
know that all of my infantry and
Cherrytree are stationed in hoti so
they're up in the hittite lands in
Turkey and then he says seven ships have
been sighted if any more are coming then
please let me know
now the story that was told for decades
was that this text had been found in a
kiln at Gujarat it was being baked
before it was shipped over to Cyprus so
it wouldn't fall apart but that the
destroyers had shown back up those ships
had come again and that the kiln and the
whole city had been destroyed before it
could be sent makes a great story again
too good to be true
reexamination has now shown that it was
not in a kiln it was in fact probably in
a basket up on the second story which
fell and landed upside down and in that
basket were this tablet and about 70
others and as the basket disintegrated
it left a kiln shaped lump with all
these tablets so in fact we now think
that it in fact was sent and this could
actually be a copy that was left so we
don't actually know it if it's from the
last sea peoples or the previous one 30
years earlier so it's not as much of a
help as we thought
and yet it's definitely evidence for
invaders we've even got another letter
it's a private letter it's one of the
last from regard which says when your
messenger arrived the army was already
humiliated and the city was sacked our
food in the threshing floor was burnt
and the vineyards were also destroyed
our city is sacked may you know it may
you know it so somebody is coming in and
destroying this area and in fact Connie
uski the same guy that took the pollen
samples when he was at Gabala and Noor
Syria he actually identified a
destruction layer as Sea Peoples but
this is a bit hasty there's definitely a
destruction layer but it's not
necessarily by the sea peoples we don't
actually know who did it so this is a
bit of
a problem and in fact I give you one
example Canaanite hot sore in the north
of Israel definitely destroyed somewhere
around 1200 BC we know this because
we've got the archaeological evidence of
the Late Bronze Age palace that is
completely torched the mud bricks or I'm
sorry the mud bricks are burnt red and
black a fire destroyed this and in fact
the excavator is actually two excavators
Amnon ben-tor and Sharon Zuckerman who
just recently passed away they were
directing the site and Amnon ben-tor
said you know what it's probably not
Egyptians that did this destruction
because there are Egyptian statues that
are in the destruction level and they're
deface they have their arms hacked off
inside so no Egyptian would have done
that so it can't be Egyptian and same
thing with the Canaanites because
there's also Canaanite statues and the
destruction and they are also defaced so
it's not Canaanites that are doing this
he says that leaves the Israelites and
the sea peoples and this is too far
inland for sea peoples and I would
actually debate that sea peoples got
quite far inland but he didn't want them
that left the Israelites Joshua and in
fact hot sore is mentioned in the Bible
as one of the cities that Josh were
burned down well Sharon Zuckerman said
wait not quite so fast this has
definitely burnt down that's for sure
but how do you know who did it he says
well what do you mean she says well if
you look and see what's destroyed it's
the palace and a couple of temples but
the actual domestic areas where the
people are living and working there
untouched they're not burnt they're not
destroyed she said to me that's the sign
of an internal rebellion of the lower
classes rising up against the upper
class when they don't have enough food
or enough money or whatever so she said
it's an internal rebellion and my point
here is very simple if the two
co-directors can't decide who destroyed
their site then how are we ever going to
decide all we know is that it is
destroyed by somebody or maybe by some
thing because we can't rule out
earthquakes and in fact if you take a
map
of the sites that are destroyed in this
collapse from about 1225 to 1175
everything you see here with the red X
is destroyed and if you overlay it on
top of a map of earthquakes that have
happened just in the last century or a
little bit more it's about 1900 you can
see that most of the sites are actually
in active seismic zones in fact we've
got a number of fault lines you've got
the North Anatolian fault line and light
blue get another fault line in green
you've got an orange one coming up the
Great Rift Valley so there are lots of
fault lines and lots of earthquakes in
this region and in fact we have
something that I find absolutely
fascinating this is the North Anatolian
fault line running across the top of
Turkey it has had what is called in
modern terms an earthquake sequence over
the last 60 or more years in fact
specifically about 1939 to 1999 an
earthquake sequence is when you have an
earthquake and it doesn't release all
the pressure there'll be another
earthquake right next to it or nearby
sometime in the future a week later a
year later maybe a decade later if that
one doesn't release all the pressure
you'll have another one and another one
until the fault line unzips this is
stuff that a most nor at Stanford
studies so earthquake sequences what
they call it when it happens in modern
times but it happened in antiquity as
well and they have a much cooler name
for it it's called an earthquake storm
when you have this earthquake storm and
it unzips over a period of 50 or 60
years it then takes about another 400
years to generate enough steam and start
the whole process over again and it
looks like if we look at some of the
sites that are destroyed that there is a
50 year earthquake storm right around
our period so I think that there are
earthquakes taking place here so for
instance my scene I here on the land
gate you can see the cyclopean masonry
on the left side and it's built on top
of what looks like bedrock there that's
actually one side of a fault zone all
the geo archaeologists went there and
just started laughing they're like
wait a minute they built the major city
on top of an active fault zone who would
do that
yeah the people from San Francisco just
kind of shook their head and in fact
we've got victims that are obviously
killed in an earthquake here is one
young lady it's actually the same one in
both pictures here and you can see the
rock that's lying to the side of her
head in the was that the right picture
for you that rock was actually embedded
in her skull she had taken shelter in a
doorway which is usually the best place
to do it in the basement but the whole
thing had collapsed and had killed her
so my scene I Terrans just three
kilometers away same sort of thing in
this case we've got a woman and a child
killed by a collapsing building at the
same time period if you go over to Troy
with the Trojan War and all that Troy 6
you've got a wall that is not supposed
to look like that right that one that's
leaning trust me it wasn't built like
the way originally and even at Garrett
this is a slightly earlier one but you
see how that wall undulate sits not
supposed to do that so there are
earthquakes at this time so here my
point would be that if you see a site
that's destroyed it might not be who it
might be what that destroyed it in this
particular case but if you do have a few
a who then you've got the cutting of
these international trade routes and
that is going on and I bring us back to
one of our original slides here where
you've got this long trade route with
the bronze and the copper and the tin
and if imagine it had been cut at any
point along that and you suddenly
couldn't get your tin anymore then how
are you gonna make your bronze now
that's not going to bring your Bronze
Age to a complete halt in and of itself
but if you add that in to the great mix
then I think you can see you've got a
problem and in fact they were lucky that
they were able to turn to iron to take
over and in fact you know in the Bronze
Age there are really oh there are
already using iron in King Tut's tomb
there's an iron dagger it's just that
they're using bronze much more and even
in the Iron Age that takes
they're still using bronze but not as
much so in this particular case we see
basically an innovation taking over to
fill the gap where they don't have
bronze anymore and they've got iron so
in terms of what happened well it's
still a mystery but I think we can sum
up if I give you three points that I
think you will agree with me and
there'll be no arguments we can then
proceed from there so first point would
you agree that we have a number of
separate civilizations that are
flourishing between say the 15th and the
13th centuries we've named some of them
Mycenaeans Minoans Hittites egyptians
canaanites Cypriots they're all
independent but they are all interacting
with each other especially through trade
routes would you agree with me with that
point ok so we've got that second point
it's pretty clear that many of the
cities were destroyed and that the Late
Bronze Age pretty much came to an end
right around eleven seventy seven or
soon thereafter we all agreed with that
no argument there everything's destroyed
everything goes down but point number
three there's no proof as to what or who
has actually caused this all we know is
that it did collapse so we've got three
main points that everybody agrees on and
yet it in a way doesn't help us all that
much and in fact people are still even
today going with that same linear
progression they still say I heard it
last November drought famine cutting of
the trade routes movement all that I
still say that is too linear it was much
much messier so if you were to say to me
well what is it
earthquakes famine drought movement of
peoples I would say yes to all of the
above in fact the only thing that's
missing is plague there's no evidence
for plague and I actually do find that
surprising I think there should be but
no evidence for that yet but everything
else absolutely we've got the whole so
the whole thing the problem is I don't
know that we can point to any one single
driver or stressor certainly climate
change seems big but is that the major
stressor or driver
that can be argued because some of the
others may have caused a problem as well
and in fact different parts of this
region ranging from remember we're going
from Italy and Greece all the way over
to Iraq and Iran in Afghanistan
different problems may have arisen in
different places and they may have
reacted differently but the ending is
the same they all end they are depending
on each other for both raw materials and
finished products and therefore when one
went down there is a domino effect what
happens to the hittites affects the
Mycenaeans which affects the Cypriots
which affects the Assyrians and so on so
anything that gets destabilized in a
system like this is ultimately going to
affect everything right and in fact what
we're looking at is the system's
collapse this isn't an explanation for
it it's just a name for it when you've
got a systems collapse and Colin Renfrew
was talking about this already back in
about 1979 you have a collapse of the
central administration you've got the
disappearance of the traditional elite
you've got the collapse of the economy
if you've got a centralized economy and
you have entire population shifts and
decline now this doesn't happen
overnight systems collapse which we can
see in a number of different places
takes about a hundred years and in fact
I would say that 1177 is the wrong title
for my book civilization did not
collapse in that year that is just
shorthand for the whole collapse just as
we say that Rome fell in 476 even though
we know it didn't it took most of the
fifth century and even then you've still
got the eastern Roman Empire continuing
on we still say Rome fell in 476 it's
shorthand if you will that's what 1177
is it's a shorthand perhaps a better way
to say it would be that the world in
1200 was very different from the world
in 1100 and completely different in the
year 1000 but that doesn't really fit on
the book cover
so we're looking at something that takes
about a century and when everything does
fall you get a dark age and in fact
we've got that we've got the Greek Dark
Ages that go for about 300 years and in
the system's collapse you frequently get
myths about the Golden Age that came
just before so think for example about
Homer and a story about the Trojan War
that's a perfect example so what I would
say that we're looking at is indeed a
systems collapse from that time period
so what are the takeaways what lessons
can we learn from this well one of the
questions we can ask is are we facing a
similar situation today now that might
be I mean its 3,200 years but let me ask
you is there climate change today well
we could argue about that till the cows
come home but I think most people now
would say yes famines and droughts
somewhere in the world absolutely
earthquakes going on yes rebellions sure
in fact I think the only thing we're
missing are the sea peoples and in fact
I'm not so sure we're missing the sea
peoples because there could be two
different groups that you can interpret
as the sea peoples they could either be
Isis which is busy destroying everything
in the Near East our antiquity is going
to be gone if we don't do something
about it
or they could be the refugees that have
fled from Syria and elsewhere that are
now in Europe it depends if you see the
sea peoples as victims or oppressors or
maybe both so I actually think we do
have the sea peoples today as well just
with a slightly different name and in
fact if we take a look at headlines from
around the world from say the last two
or three years Greece's economy is
tanked right that's been in the news
internal rebellions have engulfed Libya
Egypt and Syria Outsiders some foreign
warriors are fanning our flames yes not
news it's on TV every night turkeys
afraid it's going to be involved as does
Israel Jordan is crowd
with refugees Iran is bellicose and
threatening and Iraq is in turmoil right
all of this ripped from the headlines in
the last couple of years
well what if we had newspapers from 1200
BC what would the headlines have read
pretty much the same thing so my
question is we are more technologically
advanced we are also more aware of our
surroundings that is the Hittites did
not have SUVs they did not cause climate
change but Mother Nature did a pretty
good job of it back then I also think
the Hittites were not aware of what was
happening what was a drought why didn't
it rain I mean you pray to the storm
guide and it works or it doesn't work we
know what is happening we know what's
causing it and we might know what to do
about it the question is will we do it
now I look backwards that's my job as a
historian it is the job of others
including in this audience to look
forward so I would simply say that if a
similar globalized Society collapsed
3200 years ago might we not want to
study it a little bit to find out what
we could learn and maybe stop ourselves
from doing the same thing food for
thought
thank you
thank you sir have a seat say more about
the Dark Age 300 years of what what was
lost I mean you said you wanted to live
in the golden Bronze Age there's lots of
apparently good things but we're like
you know languages lost technologies
lost cities emptied what what what is
darkness mean in this case darkness
means totality I mean you ask what's
lost what isn't lost they lose the art
of writing the art of writing well if
you want to call it the art of read they
they forget how to write now remember
that only 1% can really write back then
so when you top when you take off that
traditional elite including the Scrabble
class you're left with not many people
who know to read and write so linear B
goes away which the Mycenaeans are using
and so on so they lose writing they lose
the monumental architecture they lose
much of what we would call the hallmarks
of civilization now they're gonna get it
back but it's gonna take a while it
takes a different period of time
depending on where you are so in Greece
for example it takes about two to three
hundred years to come back but in other
places it takes them far less for
example remember Egypt doesn't really
collapse it's just weakened and Assyria
and Babylon
they bounced back in a couple of decades
and I think the secret there's they're
all on major rivers you've got the Nile
you've got the Tigris and Euphrates so
even if you've got a drought I think
they're less affected but even they have
dark ages
so it's what happens so was there a
Renaissance where people sort of
rediscovering stuff from before and
there was a continuity or was a
completely new invention of these things
both there's both the Renaissance and
new inventions but in fact there is a
period of Greek history that we call the
Greek Renaissance and this is the period
when you have Homer Hesiod and then
Sappho in the Greek poets the eighth
century is when they're coming back up
and rediscovering
but in the meantime you've got new
things for example the Phoenicians have
brought their alphabet and so when
they're now writing in the eighth and
seventh centuries they're using an
alphabet which is completely different
from what they had done with linear B
which is basically pictograms so there's
both the Renaissance and new ideas and
one of the things that occurred to me is
you know I hate to kind of put it this
way but if you have an old-growth forest
sometimes a forest fire is good it
clears away the underbrush and lets new
things grow and that's kind of what
happened here because think about a what
if what if this hadn't collapsed would
you have the Israelites coming in would
you have Moses and monotheism would you
a couple centuries down the pike have
Greece and democracy I mean it's all
kind of so because this collapsed we've
got our world today so one of these days
I want to write something about what if
what if it hadn't collapsed what would
we be doing smart dinosaurs um question
from CRISPR so please illustrate the
scale of the cities kingdoms armies and
navies the town's well is the population
of canosa and so on but how many people
are we talking about now it's very tough
to estimate population and it depends
yes three different people you get three
different answers they have a range
problem yeah they've got a range and in
fact there's a new article out saying
can also says three times larger than we
ever thought it was at this time pruder
actually in the iron you theory or new
data a new data that's just coming out
yes but the the upshot is in terms of
cities I mean we're talking a couple
thousand people we're talking armies
that are maybe a couple of hundred
people they're not huge there is in the
Battle of Kadesh any of a couple hundred
people hundred people can do pretty
devastating attack even at you know yeah
yeah there is in the Battle of Megiddo
for example there are nine hundred
chariots that are captured that's a huge
fighting force that's actually is
absolute lot of Tanks yeah armored
cavalry armored cavalry for that time
for it we have another Hittite text that
talks about a force in the region of
Troy and about
1,500 BC and it says so-and-so landed
with a hundred men that was a lot so
we're not talking huge amounts we're
talking a couple thousand I think if a
city is ten or twenty thousand it's it's
big huge and what was in these fees that
people would want I mean it I can see
this or the the not an invasion but
Refugee approach but some of these sound
like they were you know and we're gonna
take down your city and what was there
that they would want its this slave gold
and what's there well in a lot of these
cases what it seems is at the end of the
Late Bronze Age they're burning down the
cities and then reoccupying them so
remember this is a migration they're
actually looking for places to settle
and in fact some of the archaeological
evidence is indicating that the
assimilation if you will was much more
peaceful the Canaanites and the
Philistines for example oesophagus
Orlando of Haifa is has got evidence
that these are actually maybe much more
peaceful settling down hmm so yes there
is some warfare yes there is some
destruction but they're not you know
pillaging and burning and moving on they
are even at Gabala where kind of you ski
was looking there is a destruction and
then there's an immediate reoccupation
and in that case there is this
Philistine looking pottery which is why
he thinks that sea peoples had there
been a long peace before all of this
breakdown that made these societies more
vulnerable in some sense more relaxed
about things it's possible that it is
quite possible they are definitely this
is an era of prosperity I would say from
the 14th century ons or a growing
prosperity people are growing cross
generation generation better and better
off exactly and they may have been
lulled into a sense of false security I
was at a conference a year or two ago on
climate change at this time period and
one of the people there suggested that
there was actually a time in the 14th
century of more rain and better times
and perhaps they overextended themselves
so when the ending came it was all that
more droughts
stick so yes they may have been I
wouldn't say lulled into false security
mmm
but things were going really well in the
14th and 13th centuries and in fact
that's the thing about this collapses
everything's going really well until
suddenly it's not mm-hmm it's not like
things were going badly for a while it's
a new guard for example the letters from
the merchants and the kings and all that
everything is going great until suddenly
the city's destroyed so these societies
do they have histories to themselves are
they telling stories of their own past
are they living in a kind of a rolling
prison depends on the city regard for
example has there's actually a cottage
industry of huger riddick studies
they've got history they've got King
lists they've got Queen list they've got
epics they've got so we've got that but
from others it's it's new that we don't
have anything so it just depends where
you are Steve Lavigne Asst can you
comment on the languages of the period
was there a lingua franca so they're
doing all this trade there's numbers and
then we have this accounting is there
something besides numbers that they all
absolutely excellent question and yes
the lingua franca of that day is
Akkadian which the Amarna letters that I
cited at the beginning if you were
Hittite and you were and you could read
or write you would know Hittite and
Akkadian if you were Egyptian you would
know Egyptian and Akkadian a even
probably the Mycenaeans they would know
linear be an Akkadian if you are living
in Assyria and Babylon you're home free
because you're doing Akkadian anyway
right but that is the lingua franca and
we do see the diplomatic correspondence
being written in it some of the Amarna
letters are one of them is written or
two of them are written in hittite but
that's unusual most of them are Akkadian
everybody's got their own language and
then there's one diplomatic language so
that in a sense was the Bronze Age
lingua franca absolutely absolutely well
like English
some guy writing in the dark I can't
read his name Bob Cole pocket might look
like when did the iron business start
that iron technology you mentioned
briefly that it was just getting going
in Egypt so the wear and see a little
bit about bronze technology versus iron
technology okay
this is a much debated point but
basically iron once you are able to
master the smelting and all that of
course I aren't going to be much better
than copper but copper is in some ways
seems to be easier to manipulate now
that's not always true but there is a
good reason why they are using bronze
for almost two thousand years and that
iron doesn't take over until it really
absolutely has to the actual date for
the invention of iron is a bit of a
debate and there's kind of an old wives
tale that the Hittites invented it and
had a monopoly and that's why they were
able to to capture most of the Middle
East at one point that turns out to have
been a mistranslation of one of the
texts and so while the Hittites did know
iron so did everybody else but it's the
type of thing where you're not going to
actually do it until you have to and so
I would say as I said that this is
something where if your supply of tin is
cut off and you can't make bronze
anymore you will turn to iron which
turns out to be better any which turns
out to be better anyway exactly yeah
what is this sharpness about bronze
dagger versus iron really matter how
sharp it is if it goes in you it goes in
you all that bronze says in the whole
thing edge presumably as well bronze
does not hold an edge as well I still
would not want to get attacked by it
fair enough I promise not to manual met
manometer
I think yes because they have done in
1177 to prevent the collapse good
question I've been wondering that myself
what could they have done to prevent it
who would be the day in this case it
would be the day yeah
might be in fact I think Egypt did
prepare I if lugar it is destroyed
between 1190 and 1185 which we think
mm-hmm and the Sea Peoples don't wind up
in Egypt until 11 77 that gives them a
good 7 to 10 to 15 years to figure it
out so I think Egypt was plenty prepared
in fact there's some new evidence but
colleague of mine that thinks the land
battle there's a land battle and a naval
battle and she thinks the land battle
was actually fought earlier up in Syria
and that it was kind of an offensive
defense that go protect your country it
was sort of reach the Egyptians went all
the way up and then later they fought
the naval battle down below so I do
think that they had some time to prepare
and I think that's probably why they
were successful others you know what can
you do if your if your supply of a
crucial raw material has come off it can
be difficult if you're hit by an
earthquake I don't know anything that
can prepare you for that so I'm not so
sure it was possible to have survived it
and this is one thing that I would say
if an earthquake hits you can survive it
if a famine hits you can survive it I
mean people will die but you can survive
it a drought yeah invaders yes somebody
always survives but what if you have one
then two then three and then four what
if you have the perfect storm that also
gets you a multiplier effect where
everything is gonna get worse and worse
and worse and I think that's what we've
got here so I think if it had been just
a famine they could have survived it
they've done that before we know they
had a famine back in the 14th century
they survived it we know there's
invaders they've survived it but when
you've got them all at once so they're
how do you prepare for that and I'm not
sure that you can so you've got a sort
of cascading effects you've got a chaos
leading to chaos you mentioned four
things in your slide the sort of loss of
administrative centre the loss of kind
of an economic apparatus the loss of the
elites and I forget what the
oh right the population declines on
movements hmm so do the cities really
empty out in these circumstances or what
happens some of them did some of them
that they're actually population
movements and in fact that's what Reese
carpenter was basing himself on he
didn't have the data about the pollen
and everything but he did notice the
population shifts and he said one of the
only reasons that could have caused it
was drought and then the whole thing
collapsed so indeed so we can go away
from drought that makes a lot of sense
they go away from chaos bit toward white
right ironically however one of the
major suggestions is that if the sea
peoples the shardana and the shekel ash
really did come from Sardinia and Sicily
which I do adhere to that I don't think
they went there afterward I think that
came from there the hypothesis is that
there was an original drought up in
Europe or in western Mediterranean
during their moving in which case they
have the worst rotten luck because
they're moving from one drought into
another draught right on the eastern
Mediterranean and what do you do if you
have a 300 year long drought that's
pretty hard to survive famously so Egypt
goes into a steep decline that is the
way you describe to say a little more
about that so even though they were
prepared in they're the ones that
survived what a survival mean under the
circle up evil and turmoil and
rebellions in Egypt everything is not
hunky-dory
they do survive in fact Ramses the 3rd
himself the man who saved Egypt from the
Sea Peoples it would said how he was
seen at the time is the guy who I would
upstand you don't actually have anything
that says well actually he himself says
that I'm sure he said I didn't know he
was assassinated in a harem conspiracy
it's just kind of a interesting way to
end your life in fact and it was we know
about it because it was written it's
actually a fairly famous papyrus where
it says that there was an assassination
plot and it names a minor queen who had
just
the Sun and there were something like 40
accomplices in the harem and they're all
put on trial and they're put to death
but nobody knew whether it has succeeded
the actual report doesn't say but Ramses
the thirds mummy was x-rayed in cat scan
not so long ago oh and his mummy has
kind of a scarf around his neck and when
they looked through it they just now saw
this is the last couple of years a knife
and incision by a knife that went right
in and just cut his throat basically he
would have died pretty much instantly
and so it looks like the assassination
did in fact take place now in the same
tomb they also found a young man wrapped
in a goat skin and not mummified which
is what you do when somebody is well you
don't want them to survive into the
afterlife and that mummy of the young
man shows evidence of having been
strangled to death so the hypothesis is
that that is the young prince who was
part of it and that he was then buried
with his father after the assassination
took place so even though you beat the
sea peoples you might have trouble at
home yeah yeah the most dangerous thing
is Affairs either your family or your
harem or both and Michael M asks there
are lots of mysteries what one piece of
information were you as an archaeologist
most like to find that would solve most
of the questions you have
what would I most like to find that
would solve most no would you like
somebody else before someone you know
lad Lee Reid yes do both actually vote
there's digs that you work on and
there's things to other people working
absolutely so for example at Megiddo
where I was for last 20 years
we know that the king of Megiddo be
readier in 1350 is writing to Amenhotep
authority - where Makita is Megiddo
sorry is northern Israel Jezreel Valley
if at Megiddo is Armageddon har Megiddo
in Hebrew is the mound or mountain of
Megiddo har Megiddo Armageddon army
the original rough breathing or H was
lost to us over translation so megiddo
is Armageddon and that was kind of fun
digging an Armageddon for 20 years in
fact our shirts at the back said I
survived Armageddon in heaven year well
in about 1350 the king of Megiddo is
writing to the Egyptian pharaoh and we
have six letters from him in that Amarna
archive in Egypt what we don't have are
the responses they are somewhere at
Megiddo
and that was actually why I joined the
project originally in 1994 I wanted to
find that archive in fact I think I know
where it is because Chicago who was
there 1925 to 1939 they excavated half
of the Late Bronze Age Palace and the
other half is still there waiting to be
excavated and that's probably where the
archive is hmm I was so sure we were
gonna find it in 94 I brought my
Akkadian textbooks I was prepared to
translate them on the spot oh boy yeah
we never found exactly what again return
so I would love to find the archive at
Megiddo that I know is there we just
haven't found it so but basically
writing writing writing hmm my other
side of Cobre which is a Canaanite
palace way up in the north of Israel
think right on the Lebanese border
that's where we are we've got a middle
Bronze Age Canaanite palace and in 2013
and 2015 we found the oldest and largest
wine cellar from the ancient world so
we've got about 16,000 liters of wine
it's got an earthy taste now but no it's
all gone we just have the the jars but
organic residue analysis can tell you
what was in the jars we don't have a
scrap of writing I would love to know if
they were writing were they writing too
because they've got connections to
Greece so so it's the missing tablets
that have me in a conundrum that's in my
wildest daydreams that's what I would
want to find another couple of archives
you realize that if civilization
collapses about 30 years from now
there'll be no writing and all recording
what the hell happened it'll all be in
the cloud it will be out there you know
analyzing corpses trying to find out
what they were sick with theirs I'm so
and that for me as an archaeologist is a
fascinating question as what are people
going to find from our civilization if
and when we do collapse and if there are
any future archaeologists what are they
going to think when they excavate say
the Smithsonian Museum or the Washington
zoo were all the Starbucks that are out
there well do a little taxonomy of
collapse here so the one clearly that we
in the West take most seriously was the
the collapse of the Roman Empire compare
and contrast what happened then with
what happened 1,500 years earlier 1177
well I think the the collapse of the
Late Bronze Age was at least as great as
the collapse of the Roman Empire in
terms of what we lost
hmm in terms of I mean the Babylonians
and Assyrians are doing complex
mathematics and astronomy and medicine
we've got the texts from them and from
the Egyptians right all sorts of things
that were lost all that astronomy is
lost all that was gone yeah now it's
later reincorporated I mean the we've
got the Neo Babylonians and the new
Assyrians who rise up in the first
millennium and they continue like I said
for them they only go down for a couple
of decades so they are able to have the
Renaissance right away and so we've got
a neo Babylonian astronomy for example
is quite advanced but in other cases I
mean it's so lost we don't even know
what they had hmm the Mycenaeans
their language was only deciphered in
1952 as an early version of Greek one
gets a sort of sense of trauma that
happened in the West after Rome went
down do you think it was that kind of
traumatic in the Mediterranean in the
Bronze Age went down yes I think it was
absolutely traumatic especially for the
survivors that probably didn't know what
hit them and what really what to do
about it
I mean think if you've got a complex
society and everything's ticking away
merrily and then into it like I said you
just drop a little chaos you've got
everything it's like a flying racecar
where if you throw a rod from your
engine suddenly you're driving a piece
of junk same thing here I think it had
been absolutely marvelous and wonderful
and they were going places and suddenly
it's a screeching halt and everything
stops and then you've got so these were
monumental civilizations and so you've
got you know the the thing that we saw
in a sense after Rome and after the
later demise or slowdown of Egypt of
people sort of camping out in the ruins
of a former yes yes and we do have that
we have squatters in most of these
places in fact can also us with with
them thinking that now in the Iron Age
it's three times bigger in the immediate
aftermath that probably was squatters in
fact my scene I for example Agamemnon's
my scene I there are squatters that
continue it doesn't just go down it
continues on a trickle but squatters
show up how in archaeology it's hard to
tell sometimes but when they're living
and what are obviously ruined buildings
and yet they're still living there
that's a pretty good indication see a
little more about the mention they're
talking before you're working on a
couple of stories now on being Makita
one being archaeology of the future we
had long now foundation very interested
in the archaeology the future since
we're trying to create some with ten
thousand year clock what have you got
what's what is you bear down on what
future archaeologists will find what
stands out well it's interesting
question actually it comes from the
world without us exactly got me thinking
about that and they were a couple of
specials on TV at the time so now you
know when I fly into a major city I try
and imagine what I would find as an
archaeologist in say 2000 years hmm and
of course what would be left or the
plastics and the things that are non
biodegradable probably but then I do
come to the question of how you would in
prett it's because in archeology for
example we've got a saying of course is
tongue-in-cheek but if we don't
understand something then it's cultic or
religious so our fertility right sorry
our fertility or fertility exactly so
for example I mean if you were
excavating some of the Smithsonian
museums that's gonna throw you for a
loop like what's the what's the Hope
Diamond doing next to an elephant doing
next to it but you know nabonidus and
the 6th century BC he had a museum that
was gonna say there must be historic
museums that have like that lets
everything cobble together and that
through the archaeologists for a loop
when they're finding sumerian stuff next
to babylonian stuff they're doing what's
going on they suddenly realized we're
digging in ancient museum so what if you
have something like that or what would
be left say of the zoo San Francisco Zoo
Washington zoo I if the animals got out
and you just have empty cages or if the
animals don't get out and they're still
there
what are you gonna do with that and then
really what are you gonna do with all
the McDonald's and Starbucks that are on
every corner are you gonna interpret it
religious you've got that green green
haired goddess so all I can think of we
were talking earlier about motel all the
mysteries they which a wonderful book
where they misinterpreted Motel and
they've got somebody lying in the sacred
chamber and they're on the sacred
platform and they have the sacred
communicator looking at the altar and
you realize it's a TV with the remote
and he's on the bed right shouting into
the toilet everybody makes it this great
echoing sound that was obviously a my
favorite picture is where she is wearing
toothbrushes dangling from her ears and
she's got the sanitized for your
protection right around her head and was
wearing a toilet seat and it's a
deliberate recreation of Sophie
Schliemann wearing Priam's treasure
Troy absolutely marvelous so what's the
future of archaeology I mean don't we
run out of things to dig up after a
while
[Laughter]
fortunately no there is no there's so
much past there's so much stuff in so
many places we never run out right we
will there's no such thing as peak
antique no there will always be
something the question though on a
serious note is how are we going to do
archaeology and that's one of the things
I've been wrestling with there have been
so many advances for example just in the
last couple of decades now we're using
satellite imagery right sarah park ack
the space archaeologist is finding stuff
from space some of you may have seen her
on colbert the drones that can go right
over their little area it absolutely
lidar can see through the jungles so I'm
actually getting a bit frustrated to be
honest of digging blind as I say we're a
trench down and we're not sure if we're
gonna hit something so there are ways to
look through electromagnetic and
resistivity and conductivity and things
like that but there's got to be
something out there that can actually
tell us more what we're looking for and
I suspect it's there and then somebody
here in Silicon Valley or whatever is
already using it and I just have to talk
to the right person who says basically
oh yeah we got that all right so you
know what can what can we find for
instance looking into a mound like
Megiddo which has 20 cities one on top
of another we don't do that anymore we
don't stack our cities know we're City
more's the pity
no the coastal cities may do that is
this level rises perhaps but no but they
did it they stacked them but I would
love to be able to something that would
tell me yes 20 feet down there is a
plaster floor should be able to be
something that would detect the
components of plaster I would think you
don't just drill in these nothing you
don't so I I think with
we had a major revolution with these new
sensing devices but that was for the
most part 30 years ago I think it's time
it's ripe for a new revolution the
question is what's it going to be now
the people that were digging in the 60s
could never predict a lidar or satellite
images at least not your girl's biome
analysis of you know what's in the wine
jars exactly the organic residue no
absolutely so what's it going to be like
30 years from now well that's one reason
that we don't do 100% excavation of a
site
we leave part of the site knowing that
the next generation is going to either
be better than us or have better
equipment than us now if I admired the
long-term thinking involved in that is
it actually the case that people do go
back and do another trench and so there
is a sort of a absolute return the
problem is that each time somebody else
comes they take away a little bit more
so for instance Heinrich Schliemann was
at Troy first and he actually dug right
through the layer that he was looking
for and threw it out on his back pile
right right if I had $50,000 I'd go dig
through the back pile at Troy because
that's where all the good stuff is
because Schliemann threw it out so the
next person dort felt had to dig around
the edges mm-hm and then the next person
after him Lagan had to dig around his
edges and it was only until Manfred
Curfman got there in 1988 with new
technology that he was able to figure
out that what we know of as Troy is just
the Citadel where the king and his
retainers were there is a lower city in
the plain below that expands the size of
the city by 10 or 15 times oh boy
yeah so that gets closer to the city we
hear about in horror exactly so now now
it fits better but in that particular
case had Sleeman realized there was a
lower City I'm sure there'd be nothing
there for anybody else to accident
so there's two things being discovered
here one is more swell better tools to
discover more stuff probably more
archaeologists now alive than there have
ever been I would think so yes and
archaeology is now there's not only more
of us it's more scientific than it ever
was
it's more a theory based as well and
it's more both enter and
cross-disciplinary theory in terms of
theory of archaeology a theory of what's
being discovered both okay both I would
say we're we're trying to ask bigger
questions we're no longer digging just
to dig we're not digging just oh it's a
city let's see what's there for example
at covery our Canaanite palace we are
our larger questions we're trying to
investigate the rise of rulership hmm
we're trying to look at the Canaanite
economy and try and compare palatial
versus non palatial so we're we've
actually got bigger questions that the
digging can help us answer this story
continues they'll keep finding more
stuff and what I love is you keep
finding new stories emerging from the
stuff thank you for the stories tonight
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]